>> AND NOW IF I LEFT CLIMATE
WORRIER AND THAT IS
CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA AND
CORTEZ WASN'T SEEING MUCH GREED
AT THE BOX OFFICE OVER THE
WEEKEND REPORTEDLY BRINGING IN
AN AVERAGE OF 80 BUCKS PER
THEATER FOR HER CLIMATE
DOCUMENTARY TO THE END.
NOT A DOCUMENTARY FOLLOWS FAR
LEFT ACTIVISTS AS THEY TRY TO
GET CLIMATE LEGISLATION PASSED
IN CONGRESS AS IT TURNS OUT, THE
CLIMATE CAUSE AGENDA MAY NOT BE
AS POPULAR IN DEMOCRATS IN THE
MEDIA MOB.
AND THEIR ALLIES THEY WANT YOU
TO THINK BECAUSE IT APPEARS THAT
THE DOCUMENTARY IS GOING
STRAIGHT INTO THE RECYCLING BIN.
ANYWAY HERE WITH MY LOUISIANA
SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY IS WITH US,
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBER,
THIS MOVIE GROSSES LESS THAN
$10,000 ON ITS OPENING WEEKEND.
SO, YOU ARE AVERAGING 80 BUCKS
PER THEATER.
NOW, YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A
MATHEMATICIAN FROM HARVARD
SOMEWHERE, TO FIGURE OUT THIS IS
A FLOP OR A DISASTER.
QUESTION IS, WHAT IS THAT TELL
US ABOUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE'S
ATTITUDE TOWARDS ALARMISM.
>> THE MOVIE ABOUT
CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO CORTEZ.
SEAN MAKES ME APPRECIATE
ELON MUSK.
THAT MUCH MORE.
AND THIS IS WHAT I MEAN BY THAT.
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE MADE THE
CONGRESSWOMAN'S MOVIE, SHE HAD
ANOTHER ONE BEFORE THAT WAS ON
NETFLIX.
THEY ARE PART OF WHAT I CALL THE
MEDIA ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRIAL
COMPLEX.
THEY ARE NOT ON THE
ENTERTAINERS, I'M INCLUDING MANY
DIGITAL NEWSPAPERS, MAY MEET
PAPER NEWSPAPERS, MANY
MAINSTREAM TELEVISION NETWORKS,
AND THESE ARE FOLKS WHO ONLY
PRESENT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ONE POINT OF VIEW.
AND THAT IS THE POINT OF VIEW OF
CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO CORTEZ.
MANY OF THE CONGRESSWOMAN
SUPPORTERS DO NOT LIKE AMERICA,
I THINK AMERICA WAS WICKED WHEN
IT WAS FOUNDED.
AND IT'S EVEN MORE WITH IT TODAY
AND I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE AT LEAST MILLIONS OF THEM
ARE RACIST, OR MISOGYNISTIC, AND
IGNORANT.
AND MANY OF THE SUPPORTERS OF
THE CONGRESSWOMAN ASSIGN PEOPLE
TO A STATUS.
SEE US AS INDIVIDUALS, THE ALL
WHITE PEOPLE THEY THINK ARE
RACIST, AND ALL BLACK PEOPLE
THEY THINK OF VICTIMS.
ALL WOMEN ARE POWERLESS, THEY
DON'T SEE US AS INDIVIDUALS.
THAT'S WHY I APPRECIATE WHAT
ELON MUSK HAS DONE SO MUCH.
HE IS TAKING A VERY COURAGEOUS
STAND FOR THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
THE MAN, THEY'RE BEATING ON HIM
LIKE HE STOLE CHRISTMAS, FOR HE
IS TOUGH.
HE IS TOUGH IS A PRIME LINE AND
THE MAN HAS GUTS.
HE'S GOT ORIGIN AS THE SIZE OF
PETE'S BALLS.
AND THANKS TO ELON MUSK, THANKS
TO ELON MUSK, RICK AND I HAVE TO
GET SOME NEW CONSPIRACY THEORIES
BECAUSE THE OLD MONK TURNS OUT
ALL TO BE TRUE.
THEY TOLD US, THEY TOLD US THAT
THEY WERE NOT CENTERING ON
TWITTER, AND THAT IT WAS ALL A
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
WELL ELON MUSK, HE HAS
DEMONSTRATED OTHERWISE.
>> SENATOR -- THE WORST THING
THEY DID IS THE FBI WAS LEADING
WITH EVERY BIG TECH COMPANY
WEEKLY AND THEN MEET UP TO THE
2020 ELECTION, WARNING THEM --
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE BEEN HACKED
MATERIALS AND THERE MIGHT BE A
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS FROM
FOR YOUR ADVERSARIES, IF YOU SEE
ANYTHING ON HUNTER BIDEN FOR
EXAMPLE, PROBABLY NOT TRUE.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA WANT TO
DISSEMINATE THAT INFORMATION.
ISN'T THAT THE FBI PUTTING THIS
ON THE SCALE OF A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION WEEKS OUTSIDE OF THAT
ELECTION?
DOESN'T IT SOUND LIKE THEY PUT
THAT THEM ON THE STYLE IN 2016
AS WELL?
HOW OFTEN TO SEE IF THEY ARE
GOING TO BE INFLUENCING THE
OUTCOME OF OUR PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS?
>> BUT I THINK DIRECTOR WRAY,
HAS A LOT OF EXPLAINING TO DO TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> SHOULD TO BE FIRED FOR NOT
CLEARING THIS UP?
>> I DO NOT KNOW WHO IS RIGHT
AND WRONG BUT I THINK
DIRECTOR WRAY TO PRESERVE THE
INTEGRITY OF THE FBI, AND MOST
FBI AGENTS OFFEND PEOPLE.
SO CLEARLY THEIR LEADERSHIP AT
TIMES HAS BEEN WALKING, AND I
THINK DIRECTOR WRAY HAS TO CALL
A PRESS CONFERENCE AND STAND UP
IN FRONT OF GOD THE COUNTRY AND
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO EXPLAIN ALL
THIS MEANS.
BECAUSE, I'M JUST GOING TO SAY
THESE EMAILS ON TWITTER THAT
HAVE BEEN REVEALED, THEY HAVE TO
MAKE EVERY DEMOCRAT, EVERY
REPUBLICAN IN AMERICA WHO
BELIEVES IN THE FIRST AMENDMENT
GOD.
>> YOU KNOW SENATOR, NOW HAVE
A BONE TO PICK UP A COUPLE CANS
IN THE U.S. SENATE.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN FIVE
OCCASIONS SINCE 1954 WHERE THE
GAVEL HAS CHANGED HANDS FROM ONE
PARTY TO ANOTHER.
NEVER BEFORE UNDER THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES, HAS THE CONGRESS
IN THIS CASE, THE SENATE, EVER
COME FORWARD WITH AN OMNIBUS
SPENDING BILL.
RIGHT NOW YOU'VE CALLED THIS BY
THE WORKS ON THE NIST SPENDING
AND I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT YOU
WANT TO EXPLAIN THE TERM.
BUT NOW WE HAVE REPUBLICANS
WILLING TO GO ALONG WITH
CHUCK SCHUMER AND THE RADICAL
DEMOCRATS AND GIVE THEM A
YEAR-LONG BUDGET WHEN ALL THEY
SHOULD BE DOING WAS PASSING ACR
CONTINUING RESOLUTION SO THAT
WHEN THE NEW HOUSE REPUBLICAN
LEADERSHIP GETS IN POWER,
THEY'LL BE A CHECK AND BALANCE
AGAINST THE INSANE AMOUNT OF
SPENDING THAT IS GOING ON IN
WASHINGTON.
NOW, WHILE MATURE REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES GOING ALONG WITH THIS
MADNESS.
MR. MARK >> WELL, IT CANNOT
HURT TO ASK THOSE WHO GO ALONG
WITH IT.
THIS IS WHAT I TOLD MY
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES TWO WEEKS AGO, I
THINK TO GET CONTROL OF
INFLATION, WE HAVE TO REDUCE THE
RACE OF SPENDING ACCUMULATION.
THAT IS MY GOAL IN PASSING THE
BUDGET.
AND I TOLD THE PROPONENTS OF THE
ON THE BASE, THAT THEY DO NOT
HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE TO ME GIVEN
MY GOAL, THAT THEY CAN GET A
BETTER DEAL WORKING WITH THE
DEMOCRATS AND OMNIBUS THEN
WAITING FOR A REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE.
THAT'S WHAT I CAN HAVE TO SHOW
TO ME.
NOW I'M ONLY IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND I
DO NOT HAVE THE SLIGHTEST IDEA
THAT WHAT IS ON THE OMNIBUS AND
IT ALMOST ALWAYS CONTAINS WERE
NICE, SPENDING, AND A LOT OF
EXTRANEOUS FEATURES.
I WILL SAVE THE BILL BUT THEY
GET APPROVED TO ME THAT WE CAN
GET A BETTER DEAL DOING IT THIS
WAY THAN WAITING ON THE HOUSE
MAJORITY.
OF THE REPUBLICAN MAJORITY IN
THE HOUSE AND THAT IS A HEAVY
BURDEN TO CARRY AND THERE'S NOT
A PRIVILEGE OF THE OTHERWISE I'M
GOING TO VOTE NO.
>> THERE IS NO WAY THEY CAN
PROVE THAT TO YOU AND YOU KNOW I
DO NOT KNOW IT IN ANY
REPUBLICANS OR GOES WITH IT, IS
BUYING INTO DEMOCRATIC MADNESS.
IT'S REALLY -- I CAN'T BELIEVE
THE LACK OF UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT A REPUBLICAN MAJORITY IN
THE HOUSE MEANS TO SPENDING.
AND THERE SHOULD BE THINKING OF
ALL OF THIS ON THEIR OWN, NOT
READING A TALK SHOW HOST TO